all right guys
bang bang stevens here he's got a
massive beard got the cameo hat ready to
rock and roll
thanks for doing this man thanks for
having me absolutely all right for uh
the few people who are watching this
that don't know you
let's go through your background what'd
you do before you started cameo
so coming out of duke i was an options
trader for the first five years of my
career
um so my very first job was clerking at
the chicago board of trade
in the soybean oil options pit
that's open outcome market making
literally i was
a clerk so somebody would make the trade
they'd write it on a card i take the
dupe i drop it
i'd check it with the other trader to
make sure there's no counterparty risk
and i'll drop it off at
goldman sachs's clearing desk and yeah
that was my first job
uh the hours were great uh the great
rooms only open 9 30 and 1 15 and
there's nothing you could do before and
nothing you could do after
so that was a fun first job uh you know
traded for
a while after that eventually got badged
up uh ended up at the spx
trade-in in the sibo and the spx pit so
open out dry
options really enjoyed that
while doing uh that i had the
opportunity to start a film investment
fund
so my uncle would actually produce the
movie lone survivor
among a bunch of other ones irishman was
his most recent
um and when blood survivor came out i
ended up running a theater
for all the guys in the pit to go how to
do a premiere
and at that a bunch of the guys that
traded with we were like stephen why the
hell are you
you know training the pit with us and
why aren't you in hollywood being a
movie producer like your uncle
so i did what any entrepreneurial you
know young greek hustler would do i
stayed in the pit and i started raising
25 g's a pop from all the guys that
probably would have pissed it away
you know better than sports uh there
wasn't crypto
at that point uh you had to be
speculating on it at least
that much in their 2011 2012 so this was
still
you know i'll take the under of the
first half of uh
you know a college basketball game
between you know rutgers and towson or
something like that
so these guys were happy to part with
their money and tell their wives and
their girlfriends that they were
investing in movies and television shows
uh
i started doing that i met my now
co-founder martin
we started a film investment fund where
we produced
a couple movies and television shows if
you guys are really bored you can watch
safe saf3 on amazon prime right now
probably the worst television show ever
made but amazon prime just launched it
about
seven years after the release so we were
catching up on that last night
which was a lot of laughs uh remake of
baywatch in 2013 with gopros and dolph
lundgren
is david hasselhoff so if you guys want
something fun
uh go watch that give it a shout out
maybe we get some residuals
you know for all the money we lost on
that investment but anyways
um so i ended up in linkedin after
trading
i'd say one thing that really hit my
mind when i was trading i remember
walking into the cboe for the first time
and this is a place where over 40 000
options traders you know worked and at
this point
you know back back in the day every
stock had its own
pet you know amazon apple had their own
pits
and suddenly you know ge had their own
pit and i walked in and it looked like a
dinosaur
graveyard there were only about a
thousand open outcry
traders left there were really two pits
it was the vix and the spx the spx was
the biggest
but i remember thinking for training
it's like all the good times that kind
of happened already
and of course as the new guy you know i
was hearing stories about what i missed
in a way with the flashcraft but i
missed with the flash crash
but i missed the 08 you know what i
missed then uh the 2001
99 and trading all the big stuff that
happened already
and um i was very fortunate that a buddy
of mine from duke recruited me to come
work at linkedin
and then when i got to tech it was
totally different and linkedin all the
good stuff was gonna happen
it was about having a mission and a
vision and realizing that
and um i ended up you know having kind
of my dream job at linkedin working with
amazing people
you know getting to learn from people
like mike gibson and jeff weiner
you know how to build culture um you
know how to work with
you know people in different offices it
was just a totally
a total game changer for me and um
we had the idea for cameo leaving my
grandmother's funeral of all places
it's october 5th 2016. martin flew in
from la
for the day for my grandmother's funeral
uh he was an nfl agent at the time when
i went to go work at linkedin
he had the idea that if he could sign a
sixth round draft pick
that was a big muscular guy with a big
personality
he could maybe back into signing the
next rock for the next chase in momoan
turn him into a huge
action start uh he signed the guy he
wasn't able to turn him into a movie
star
so suddenly he had a big you know cash
liability um
you know by by backing this guy that he
was having to pay for his training
but there was no way he was ever going
to recoup the investment
and he pulled out his phone and he
showed me a video that
gun made for his good buddy who was
pretty high up in nike's marketing
department
he loved the seattle seahawks more than
anything and become
a father for the first time and
he made this video and said hey brandon
this is cash marshman seattle seahawks
congratulations on having your son
maverick i hope he gets your athletic
ability
and if so he'll be playing with me on
the seahawks one day gohawks
in this video i saw the guys you know
cash's marsha's tatted up
guy wearing no shirt driving in southern
california
just a really compelling piece of
content you didn't
have to know who brandon was you didn't
have to know who cash was but there was
something magical about it
and martin showed me this video and the
second i saw and i had the eureka moment
and it's like
that's the new autograph and it was so
obvious to me that
you know today when you see someone
famous today you pick up your phone and
try to take a selfie with them and if
it's not on
instagram it didn't happen i grew up in
chicago and you know
90s bulls you saw ron harper you saw
you know dickie simpkins at a restaurant
you're pulling the menu out you're
signing the menu they're signing your
shirt they're signing your hat
and you know that that menu ends up on
your wall
and you know a house like mine in
glenview illinois
or you know i think back to the 98 cub
season opening day today shout out
welcome back baseball but i think back
to
nine summer in 98 you know trying to get
sami sosa or mark grace to sign
something but you
end up with rod beck or glenn allen hill
and scott service
and 20 years later i shouldn't remember
their name but because they did one
thing
nice for me one time you become a fan
for life
and really that's kind of what we try to
build with cameo we tried to
build a platform where every time
somebody made a cameo
the person who received them becomes a
bigger fan of them for the rest of their
life
and uh you know fast forward four years
we've now got 40 000 people on the
platform
we've done 1.2 million of these
we call these not candles we call
magical moments every time we make one
we really feel that
you know we're making people smile
laughing cry we're totally
changing an inflection point or being an
inflection point
it changed in their in their day and um
you know we've just been blessed to be
off to the run that we're on and
and um you know we think it's early you
know it's it's spring training ball
still for
for us we don't even think we're at the
top of the first inning yet and how big
this could get
all right before we get into cameo i got
a lot of questions but i grew up in
north carolina
in raleigh and so i know shooter's bar
at uh at duke there you got to tell
what's the story with you and uh ryan
joking around
yeah uh samadooki um
i actually again this is another kind of
tie to technology
and did network effect not knowing that
i was doing network effect businesses
back then
uh but i was a freshman at duke and one
of my
really good friends from home is a guy
named zach maritas a
big crypto guy uh today he's the
founder of the company called teamworks
which is a it's a serious c company
out of durham north carolina so you know
big shock if you knew zach and either
we're both running tech companies now
but anyways um so zach invited me to
partner with him and we in the very
early days with facebook this is when he
still needed
a edu address to come on you know he was
the senior that knew everybody i was the
freshman that knew everybody
we combined forces we created a company
called spartan entertainment we're both
greek
our dads are both literally from sparta
and we ended up
aggregating over 17 000 college students
in this facebook group
and over over the course of four years
we came to really dominate
uh nightlife you know at uh
certainly and then we started getting
into raleigh and and chapel hill by the
end of it
um but we we basically ran uh
shooters too you know it started with
our first entrepreneurial hustle was
taking the most popular bar on campus uh
which at the time was just a biker bar
really it was a bar that
uh you would go to at the first week of
school and the last week of school
and then it was just a kind of a redneck
biker bar at the meantime
and we we rented it out on wednesday
nights which was
kind of the athletes friday nights
because duke you weren't allowed to
drink
48 hours before your game so we figured
what you know if you had a friday game
or saturday game wednesday
was your was actually your saturday as
an athlete and we started
getting three dollar uh pictures and and
we set up beer pong tables and started
having that
and today if you go to duke on wednesday
night our legacy is living strong i
think that's my
that is my legacy to duke uh wednesday
night beer vlogger shooters
that is an incredible story um all right
so when you start cameo what what's kind
of
the first couple of things you guys do
so you see this piece of content you're
like bam this is
you know kind of the new autograph do
you immediately say we gotta go build a
tech platform and kind of build a
marketplace and and
you know what it comes to today or is
there some other idea you start with
well the the first thing i did was we
literally had the idea as i was driving
him from
you know we were downtown chicago and
he'd always wanted to go to trump tower
because he gets a beautiful building i
live across uh trump hadn't won
the presidency yet so it was still fine
to go to trump tower but anyways
so we go get a cocktail on the roof we
have the idea
i drive him to o'hare the second he gets
through security he calls me up
and it's basically like man this is
awesome this is exciting we're kind of
getting each other
worked up so i'm like screw it i'm going
to get on a plane to la the next day so
i flew to l.a the next day
and martin and i kind of dreamed up this
marketplace where for x amount of money
you could do y activity with z person so
the video was one thing but we thought
we could sell autographs or personalized
merch
or you know anything you know tweet at
me like follow me on instagram any
anything you met
you know from brett farm throwing a
football with you
to anything you could possibly imagine
like we just felt x amount of money why
activity with z person
uh martin and i are neither of us are
technical so
the first thing we needed was the part
you know find somebody that could come
build it
and i had a buddy from duke named devin
townsend
um that was the best engineer that i
knew who
actually happened to have been an early
vine star as well
so devon in 2014 him and his best friend
cody who's now cody kell one of the
biggest youtubers on earth
they decided to quit their jobs at apple
and microsoft respectively
they went down to bali they started
messing around on vine they spent a year
traveling the world
and devon ended up with about a billion
loops on vine
and cody had 3.6 billion loops on by
so they had actually become more famous
than they were rich they were never able
to monetize that at all but they really
understood becoming a creator devon
moved back to la
you know he started being the first
engineer at different startups
um he was at one that was just kind of
floundering and i i told him the idea
you know he didn't think much of it but
he was a friend and i think he caught
his best friend rate and
was uh we were paying him 150 an hour or
something like that
uh before he became a official
co-founder
and i think remember it was like
december and we had a 17 thousand dollar
bill so i was still working at linkedin
at the time
martin's not a fellow agent that's
losing money on his only client
so i remember we brought that check over
and it's like sure we need to we need a
little better deal here and we cut devin
in
uh got the hourly rate down gave him
some upside it was a good trade for
everybody
uh involved and um and you know devon
was really the perfect person to build
this
um i mean how many ctos how many heads
of product on earth
were actually influencers themselves so
he he intimately understood the problem
and you know devon also brought a
discipline that martin and i
did not have we were like you know let's
do the autograph like
anything we could think of it's like
let's build a site that does everything
and devin was really he's like we need
to be focused we need to pick the
vertical so
we decided to go with pro athletes first
and we really felt like again we're
building the
new autograph and the problem we were
trying to solve was uh you know
espn had released a documentary called
broke and they talked about how
eighty percent of nfl players go broke
within
five years of playing their last game so
we were thinking about that problem a
lot and again that's not a problem that
a lot of people like wake up like trying
to solve but it you know it's it's
certainly
one as athletes or as people that had
been around
athletes and there's just something that
we were thinking about and
this gap between fame and monetization
was just another big theme we you're
thinking about so we decided to focus
first just on athletes and and you know
if you're building a marketplace
to connect you know athletes with their
biggest fans and you have no athletes
and you have no fans you better pick
you know you go with the chicken or you
go with the egg we picked the chicken
first
and we really had a conviction that if
we can recruit
athletes to the platform they all have
twitter followings they all have
instagram followings and if we got them
on and we kind of made a sample video
we would be able to get them to promote
on twitter to promote on instagram
and turn their followers into our
customers for free so that was
very much the conviction that we always
had in our marketplace
supply could beget demand um
when we launched i'll never forget
launch date it was uh
it was it was mid march i was in
i literally was in arizona i was in
scottsdale trying to get the second
person
uh on cameo we had one person on at this
point you know we'd get on a plane we'd
go anywhere if someone wanted to talk to
us
and jason keptness the guy who grew up
around me was
also our second baseman for the
cleveland indians at the time
guy worked with linkedin was his best
friend he knew about the idea stephen
let's go we get we pack the bags we go
to arizona
to go pitch kipnis to get him to sign up
so he you know and of course
i get there talk to him about it and
immediately he's like yeah sure i'm in
right
it's like i have like three more days
there so
anyways it was a tuesday night i'll
never forget it's about 10 o'clock
and uh we built the very first version
of the site
and today you go to cameo there's 40 000
people there's a million videos
and literally imagine a google form that
just said you know
who like there's only one talent so
there was no even other profiles it was
like who's the video for what's your
email what does it say that's
it and i'll never forget
we we took the cameo that was the first
one that gave us the idea we had cassius
send a tweet
and basically said hey i'm on this new
thing called cameo for 20 bucks
i can make a video like this for you
saying anything you want to whoever you
want
you know can't wait to hear from you and
he clicks he
clicks twitter i was at a restaurant in
scottsdale the guys were in venice beach
so devin
martin my co-founders and cassius the
only talent on cameo
were all in that speech at devin's
apartment
cassian sends the tweet out there are
two dots there is one
in scottsdale one in la
he hits tweet we expect there to just be
a flood and who was crickets
nobody else came to say and immediately
you know we're we're looking and you
know i'm like ah [ __ ] maybe google's not
working so i literally
i've signed off in the dot and
scottsdale went away i came back
and it's like no it's not that google's
not working and then at the same time on
twitter
caches just started getting eviscerated
i'm talking
you know you're a millionaire athlete
for 20 bucks how much is this company
paying you
he just given us 25 g's as our first
investor
you know so he's pissed off you know
everybody's ribbing him on twitter
he gets pissed off hey screw you guys
i'm out he
leaves he walks out martin's freaking
out our other co-founder because
suddenly his only client is now out
money he's given us
and now his brand is getting tarnished
on twitter
so he runs after him and devin and i are
just having a conversation like
wow you know maybe yeah maybe we should
have left
our jobs you know like before we sold
one we were now three four months in
you know this is the only thing we were
doing and uh and as we're talking a dot
popped up in rent in washington which is
uh where the santa seahawks facility is
and somebody came outside and were like
wow you know i remember literally being
on the edge of my
i was on my elbows like leaning in with
my phone on
you know google analytics like what are
they gonna do what are they gonna do
and this person must have been on the
side for two to three minutes
and it felt like two to three hours
because we're like are they gonna buy
what's gonna happen
and all of a sudden the dot just
disappears and we were so dejected
because it was like
somebody's there we thought they might
buy and begin
you know our this is a disaster i need
to try to
you know get back to linkedin while they
take me back like whatever
and uh and then all of a sudden my phone
starts vibrating and i get the message
i get a message in my dm and this guy
goes hey
hey cameo uh this is you know blah blah
blah
my daughter lane uh loves cash's march
and it's her birthday on thursday i'm
trying to buy a video
from your service but the payment
process is not working so at that point
i'm like
just tell me what to say what's the name
like we'll get it done don't worry about
money
you know go and and and the guys gives
me the information i text
cash no response i text martin you know
he's pissed off of me they're pissed off
it was tuesday the birthday was thursday
we missed thursday
you know it's now the next wednesday
when i finally get this video back it
was the most unenthusiastic video i'd
ever seen
lane heard your dicks fans sorry i
missed your birthday
see you out there like it was it was so
bad i skipped this video i was cringing
i didn't even want to send it
but i'm like you know what [ __ ] it like
it's just good to do
i'm gonna send it we'll see what happens
so we ship the video
and about 30 minutes later
i get a video back and this dad records
his daughter watching the video
and she literally started crying she was
so happy this girl is wearing a seahawks
jersey her hair is literally
painted blue and green it's like
seahawks super fan
and she watches this video and she
starts crying
and she goes dad how did you do that and
he goes daddy's awesome that's how
like if we made a commercial for super
bowl it wouldn't have been better than
this
and he sent it back and then the second
i had that
like that i still get the chills you
know down my spine thinking about it
because
the second we saw we could make one
person feel like that we had high
conviction we could make
millions of people feel like that and
then when we were going to athletes it
wasn't like hey join this marketplace
where there's
you know no fans and there's no other
talent
it's like now the question was we would
show them the video
don't you want to make your fans feel
like this and people said yes
and that's really how we got it so
as you're doing that what was the
biggest pushback from the athletes first
because
you're building this marketplace right
you guys focus on the athlete's side you
go to them
and i've got to imagine like yeah i want
to feel i want my fans to feel that way
but like
who else is on right how much can i make
like all these normal questions what
were the
the big obstacles there yeah all of them
uh and i would even go one more
uh at the time any type of
direct-to-consumer modernization of fans
was like super weird
right it's one thing and for patreon to
do it and you're like a long tail
podcaster or musician and you have no
other funds and
you know it's not that weird to ask your
your your followers to support you
but these are like athletes making
millions of dollars in that case
and you know they were worried about
their brand they were worried about
selling out they were worrying about
charging their fans for something like
this
they were worried that nobody was on it
you know is
is cameo even gonna be the one right
like
you know early days of platforms there's
no gear like at some point you start
getting escape velocity but
you know there's seven other companies
that had tried this that never got any
traction
you know we found out later right so
there were there are people that have
been burned
you know uh probably the one we were
hearing the most about at the time was
called enthusia which was uh
tiki barber i think was part of it so
yeah these are like
serious athletes and entrepreneurs
teaming up
trying to do similar things weren't able
to do it uh
i think steve aoki had founded one with
like dan bilzerian
you know a few years before we got going
so people had tried it
but what we had pretty high conviction
was we really never set out to like
build something
that lebron james would do we really
thought there was an opportunity with
cameo
to help people like you know my good
friend lance thomas on the new york
knicks who
you know wasn't the superstar he wasn't
carmelo anthony
but he's like the beloved player that
gets out of the community
you know people love him huge
personality we really thought there was
an opportunity for
to serve those type of people versus
that said i'd be lying to you if i told
you we really found product market fit
with
you know backup quarterbacks you know or
practice caught
uh you know left tackles we found
product market fit one day
when devon walked uh down to our morning
meeting
and he goes hey steven i think cody his
roommate cody ko with three million
youtubers at the time
and people like cody you know x vine
stars would do really well on this
and we put cody in uh on a cameo
uh he made he we actually did
we bought him a cameo for a youtube
video that he made that went hyper viral
he decided to launch himself on the
platform he popped off
and other similar kind of dinosaurs
popped off
then that started the expansion into
reality tv
and comedians and today sports is still
probably
we're famous for for sports we kind of
came up
as the new autograph but as our business
it might be 10
now and you know we've really found
product market fit for people that are
huge personalities or people that are
really funny
how did you grow the consumer side right
so it's kind of
uh sounds like you just went and did the
hard work of recruiting
you know personality after personality
or athlete after athlete
where do all of the users come and you
know how do you convince them to
actually pay for this stuff
well just like anytime you're inventing
a new
completely new product right the best
way for
people to know what it is is to like
experience it or see it and
you know a couple interesting growth
dynamics that
that we benefit from number one um all
of our supply
unlike grubhub or uber or
any other marketplace you you think
about our supply can
literally market themselves right they
have they're famous they have
instagram they have twitter they have
followings and their fans are the most
likely
people in the world to book them so that
was a big thing like
our supply can get its own demand that's
really an important concept of cambodia
secondly we always say that every cameo
is a commercial for the next one
so just like i was able to show athletes
once i had the first reaction video
don't you want to make people feel like
this the
the customer flywheel was i buy you a
cameo you shared a twitter you have 300
000 followers on twitter
they all see this roast that i get
michael rappaport roasting you
they're like what is that that's amazing
we had to we had the watermark there
people started learning then they go to
the site
cameo oh my god look at all these people
that are there so it's really
it's really the flywheel effect of
supply be getting its own demand and
then
the fact that every cameo is a
commercial for the next one eighty-five
percent of them are gifts
the vast majority of cameos are shared
on social
so that's the plywood and
today you've got what i'll call kind of
the the traditional cameo which is
literally
hey it's my friend's birthday i buy
somebody sends them
the video you also have these
promotional ones and then you've got the
roast maybe talk a little bit about the
different variations of
how somebody can buy or what message
they can expect
so the first one the uh the promotional
cameos is
is a is actually a product that we've
had for a while
um basically what we found was
five percent of cameos that are booked
get to climb today
right so the talent can say yes or no to
anything when we dug into declines we
found that 60
of declined cameos were actually small
businesses looking for
kind of cheap influencer marketing so we
went back to our talent and we said
hey uh brett favre waukesha chevrolet
has a uh fourth of july sale coming out
you know they they wanted to book a
cameo i know you didn't want to do it
for
400 bucks but would you do it for 5 000
would you do it for 10
whatever the number is and we found that
the talent were all with
almost all would be willing to do to
create assets that companies could use
for
for their own instagram or their own
social media they just want to do it for
more
money so very quietly we added for
yeah i think there's five or six hundred
of our 40 000 talent opted into this
today
where you might see on the when you go
to cameo.com is this for myself
is this for someone else or is it for my
business and if you hit for my business
the price changes and it's more
expensive
um the second product uh that we
released that's gotten a lot of fanfare
recently is cameo live
and uh cameo live is our first stab it's
sacred as
video conversations so basically it's
literally
well not basically it's literally
getting out of zoom with you know
your favorite uh talent and um that one
is something that's captured the
imagination
i think people when they first saw cameo
they always assumed
or in the future you know face time is
obviously something that they're going
to get into
but frankly until covered we really
resisted it because we felt that
the coordination needed like it was so
much logistically harder
to say you know hey stephen what are you
doing at 4 42
central time right like pick up your
phone for this
thing and then frankly like devin as
talent always believed
that like fan conversations are just
kind of awkward right it's like
you know a lot of and this is why candy
works because when you go
run up on somebody that's eating at a
restaurant like they freeze you freeze
you know what to say
like we've all kind of been there so we
we really had pretty high conviction
that synchronous wasn't going to be a
thing
but as june became so prevalent
you know since coven like the talent was
excited about it
you know now that my mom and her friends
play their card games on
zoom it's like everybody's using it so
at this point
it became a very natural extension and i
think we have about 100 talent that
we're testing with cameo live and so far
the feedback's been incredible uh the
feedback actually has been
we launched 10 minute zoom calls because
we felt like 30 minutes would be awkward
or if it was weird you want to cut
pull the cord but what we found is like
every one of the conversations basically
people are like i want to stay on longer
the talent and the fan are having fun
they're staying on
so that's um that's a product that we're
excited about
and then and then our third product we
have is called cameo direct
and canon direct is in the app it's our
texting product
so if you there's talent that have
enabled you to actually text with them
and have an ongoing conversation so
that's you know that's super interesting
and
and we think all of these are are parts
of building out that equation
for x amount of money being able to do y
activity with z person
walk me through the funding of the
company and then we'll get into some of
the questions that people send in but
how have you kind of funded this
it started uh martin and i you know
bootstrapping it so my
money from linkedin was going into
devin's pocket is at 150 an hour best
friend rate
you know i i i don't know if that was
actually best runway or not but
but uh so we started there we we
bootstrapped it for about five months
um while i was at linkedin every single
person that i worked with like it was
i had one quarter while i was still at
linkedin when i was working on this at
the same time
and honestly i was probably the worst
employee at the company that last year
uh martin would call me in the middle of
the day i'd miss like a sales call
like i just i just remember but i was so
distracted and all the
like the people that i worked with all
like got it right away
and now about five or six of them are
working for us which is kind of funny
of the people that sat within like 10
feet of me while i was at linkedin but
you know we were basically going to uh
build a billion dollar company while
staying on our
our fat salaries and our free lunches in
linkedin
and and then i remember the big turning
point for me actually happened
uh linkedin gives christmas eve
through the first week of the year off
for all employees and i went to
nicaragua with about 10 people that i
work with
and we were sitting on a hot tub in
nicaragua on new year's day
and this guy will hearn who was a buddy
of mine worked
in other offices like stephen this idea
is so big like
if somebody else builds it and becomes a
billionaire
and you stay at linkedin and never like
take a shot could you live with yourself
and honestly nobody had ever asked me
that question
but the answer was so obviously no that
i never went back i wrote my next play
letter which
you know it's kind of funny you can go
on my linkedin profile and actually see
my next play letter and i shared the
letter that i
sent to my team and i actually never
went back to work that was
i never went back i went right to los
angeles after
i you know got martin and devon and i'm
like we need to burn the boats and just
try this and
i'm not asking you guys to quit your
jobs yet but i'm going to do it
and i just felt like that momentum was
needed so you know for me i kind of
needed that kick in the ass
and you know very shortly after
i decided to go full time that's when
like
your friends and family were wanting to
bet you know
i've never asked anybody for anything i
was always the ultra connector the
helpful person
so now when i had something that i was
gonna do
that's when people were like okay let me
get money let me get money
but the one that was most life-changing
was
uh exactly three months after me leaving
linkedin
this guy mike gibson who was the top of
the global sales org in linkedin
just cold calling me in the morning he's
like stephen i've been hearing what
you're up to
give me a call and i called him back and
uh
on the spot you know led a 500 000
you know angel investment that you know
he's like i think this is awesome i
think this should be built here in
chicago and
frankly if he didn't give me the money
cameo would have never been able to be
built in chicago
and once he came in it was just a series
of fortuitous events
you know the second day of this guy
named jackson jen
uh his his vc career he just graduated
notre dame he was
an associate at chicago ventures he got
locked in the merchandise smart in
chicago
couldn't figure out how to uh he
couldn't figure out how to get out
and uh of the building he was locked in
because he's working after eight
elevators shut down and he saw me and my
team working
came in met us thought cameo was the
most amazing thing ever
next morning he goes to uh ezra goldston
who was at chicago ventures at the time
and a big cryptic guy as well
and in ezra um literally like jackson
you know you're just falling in love
with the first entrepreneur you've ever
met
you know like a million people have
tried this it's not going to work it's
not going to be built here whatever
and jackson's like ezra you need to take
a meeting with steven this is different
and uh ezra met me he put in 100k on the
spot so chicago ventures now is their
first
adventure investment and then frankly
since then every one of our rounds has
been
preempted we've we've never made a pitch
back like this has
been incredible um you know ezra
uh ended up leaving chicago ventures to
start his own fund called starting line
um
he ended up co-leading the round with
chicago ventures and origin ventures in
chicago and her seed rounds
all of our early money came for the
midwest and then
lightspeed ended up leading our series a
jeremy liu
who famously was the first money in
snapchat saw camus
party uh asked for the intro sent an
email that was basically like
steven cameo's genius i don't know where
you are in the world but we're having
breakfast
tomorrow we ended up meeting had a
i was 10 seconds into my pitch now
because steven i've been looking for a
business like this for 10 years
basically like
shut the [ __ ] up i get it and and
i flew to los angeles from san francisco
to l.a that day
i met another lightspeed uh partner
named nicole quinn
in the lax airport i was just texting
her today because i passed
the coffee shop we met we had a meeting
there i walked around onto the plane
basically
she came to fly out to chicago the next
week or series a was done
and then uh and then about four months
after that connor perkins came in and
led
you know 50 million series b into the
company
so again we've been really blessed
because these investors
they've had a high conviction because
they've been customers they've bought
them
they've received them they understand
the power
and then when they learn more about the
business there's only two things you
have to really believe to understand how
big candy could get
number one you have to believe that
there are more famous people on earth
today than any time in history
right like just think about quarantine
uh tiger king comes on and carol baskin
goes from somebody nobody had ever heard
of or i guess a million people on
facebook had heard of
to someone that can make a quarter of a
million dollars right in in a month on
candy
it's unbelievable and and then you have
all these other people just popping up
on tick tock every day on soundcloud on
youtube on instagram
so as there's more content as content is
exponentially increasing
the amount of fame in the world is
exponentially increasing so
there are more famous people than ever
and then secondly people today are more
famous
now than they've ever been at any point
in history last
summer little nasdaq's released the song
old town red
you know he now has tens of millions of
followers and even if he's a one-hit
wonder
he now has a platform upon which he can
monetize forever
so within a post cameo world in a
post-social world
your 15 minutes of fame is something you
can live on the rest of your life
think back 20 years ago when when
trouble when
chumbawamba created tub thumper and who
knows where they are today right
because they didn't have social they
didn't have a platform so there's no
stickiness
so all those millions and millions of
people around the world that love their
work
it's just not it's not around anymore
and uh you know even on the sports side
you're a north carolina guy
and i was talking to danny green about
this last week
you know he played on that those teams
with tyler hansbrough and hansbrough was
you know the best maybe college
basketball player since christian later
just absolute legend
and because he wasn't like because he
did it
you know 10 years too early he only has
21 000 followers on instagram
right and then zion williamson had 2.1
million followers before he played his
first game
so the people coming up are more famous
than the ones that came before
and all you have to believe is that this
is just an area under the curse like
there's more fame in the world and then
people are more famous in magnitude than
ever and because of the way these
platforms work
the the wealth distribution it's like
the power laws are crazy
you know on youtube the top three
percent of creators makes 97
of all the ad revenue tick tock didn't
have any way to monetize creators until
i saw today they announced
a 200 million dollar fund to basically
you know almost put people on retainer
to just
keep making content for them um spotify
the top one percent of
musicians streaming make like 99 of the
revenue the same is true in pro sports
the same is true
when you think of endorsement deals
there's five people in the nba that have
studios right
so when you look at all this people are
more famous than ever before
and the gap between fame and
modernization has just been getting
wider and wider and wider
it was just the perfect storm for a
business like cameo
to come to allow people to monetize
their fans in a way that
is brand positive it's value prop
in the fame economy is that you're
getting paid to become more famous
when you get a cameo from someone you
like them more than you like before
and you got paid to do that it's the
ultimate
so i got a ton of questions from people
many that you and i both know uh
pretty well ian borthwitt who is the uh
the influencer marketing guy at uh seat
geek and uh
is very very deeply entrenched in the
influencer world said uh will cameo go
real world like at some point will it
actually be you can pay to have somebody
show up for an appearance
i mean it's funny you know in the
covered world that's the last thing in
the world we're thinking of but
if you look at what we're doing with
cameo lab right now
we're building the mechanisms for
bookings right like
the first step is like coordination of
calendar when are you available
how do we do it will you show up right
then
adding location it's something harder
it's it's something that we've strayed
away from because
frankly i think that asynchronous
conversation
or even us being on zoom together right
now is probably like 95
as good as us being in person but it
might be like
one percent of the effort of you know
you coming out to chicago
and like us sitting down somewhere right
look think about how much
effort saved so for us i do believe that
cameo live
aka live experiences uh meeting people
in real life
is something that will happen assuming
the world goes back to normal
one day there's just a it's very
logistically difficult and
you know tell us there's just a million
things we can do you know that are
really tech enabled first
that kind of give you like almost
the same experience without having to
worry about the logistics of location
and safety
makes sense who's the most requested
talent that's not on cameo
um for a long time it was you know funny
ian that's the first question for a long
time it was david gilbrip
actually um who he's famously done a lot
of
stuff with at cp giving away cars all
that
he's a big vlogger for those of you that
don't know who david dobrik is really
funny
you know a lot of people think he might
be the next jimmy kimmel like he's
that talented um the most
requested person recently has been like
the
rock um you know you that's that's the
one that
you know everybody would love to to get
on the platform on the customer's side
uh but you know people like taylor swift
people like bieber
um are are requested but not as much
as the dobriks of the world the shane
dawson's historically of the world
the casey neistats so we we have a
really interesting dynamic
where the majority of users on cameo
like the people coming to the website
are actually like
18 to 24 but our purchasing demographic
is actually older
uh 20 25 to 34 35 to 44
45 to 54 and 55 to 64.
and then 65 plus all by more than 18 to
24
because of disposable income and who can
afford it
you know for someone like my dad getting
you know jerry west
to wish his buddy happy birthday for 400
bucks like that's like the bargain of a
lifetime but for
you know someone that loves uh jake paul
getting
paying 200 bucks to him is like man am i
going to go to coachella or am i going
to do that like the trade-offs are
different um
so we found that the a lot of the people
want
the digital talent that's probably the
people that get requested the most
um and i'm sure if i look at the last
three months worth of data i'm sure joe
exotic would probably be the most
requested person we don't have
we got carol baskin i saw that people
were real hyped when she came
yeah she was she was there for a while
and it's kind of funny because
i reached out to her like immediately
after tiger king
and basically she they told me to have
off and uh
and you know it's kind of funny that now
she's just been this
superstar how'd you get her what finally
got him across the line
um honestly i don't i don't even know
somebody on the team uh got through to
the charity and she's doing all for
charity i mean she raised
i think in her first two weeks she did
like a quarter of a million bucks
and it's all going to big cat rescue so
you know what you know in a world where
all these parks are closed
and i mean what an awesome way to be
raising the cost
yeah uh shervin pichevar asked who are
the top 10 in earnings so maybe not
exactly go through the top 10 but just
who are some of the people who do the
most
volume yeah there's a couple of
archetypes of people that do really well
historically uh last year
the top broker was gilbert godfrey so
again comedians do extremely well
i think this year uh last i saw
kevin from the office brian baumgardner
was kind of the top of the heap
he's doing great a lot of these viral
stars um from netflix shows like jerry
harris from shears have done extremely
well
uh the real housewives is a vertical
have done incredible so
the sodium organs of the world do really
really well uh hall of fame athletes is
another
place where we do uh really well so a
brett favre
has consistently been you know a top
earner
on the platform uh the bachelor
franchises is big and some like chris
harrison or lance bass
uh you know boy bands have done good
nostalgia is a whole does really well
and when i think of the product market
fit for cameo if you were to take out a
one dollar bill
and you're to look at the back of the
pyramid
right um i think cameo has great product
market fifth the second you have your 15
minute spin
all the way until you become the most
famous person on earth
and then at some point for some people
that that curve those the
basically the the gap between fame and
modernization that we talked about like
those curves just inflect and there's
actually a point where you become more
rich than you are famous
it's like michael jordan would nev would
probably never be killed
he he we've heard him turn down 10
million dollars for a golf
outing i knew that paul mccartney turned
down like
seven million dollars to play someone's
wedding before right these are things we
just heard
being in the industry and all that stuff
so
i think there's a point where that
curving flex
but then the thing that's kind of cool
about cameos cameos also someone
somewhere where you can go when you were
the most famous person in the world and
you're not anymore
right so retired nfl players like if
you've got a gold jacket you're on
camera almost every hall of famers
when you're talking about the ray
lewis's of the world the brett favre's
um you know it's it's amazing emma smith
just joined today right so it's like
the people that you know you expect to
be there are increasingly there which is
exciting
and you know a lot of people get caught
up in the
three to five hundred people on earth
that might be at the higher the pyramid
that are
more famous than they are rich or more
rich than they are famous
and and frankly if those people were on
they'd probably be priced at a point
where most people wouldn't
be even be able to afford it so while
everyone says they might want to
switch like taylor swift might need you
know five grand or ten grand
how many of those could she actually do
so i think
we haven't built a product yet for
the super a plus list and um
we think we can build a massive business
without them we think that there's
the problem of people being more famous
than they are rich it literally doesn't
exist for those people
so we want to focus on building great
products for the people we have product
work and fit for
and the thing that's kind of cool is
like as we've gone along people like
snoop dogg who are
some of the most famous people in the
world or you know
kyrie irving or pete alonso like these
guys now are just seeing cameo think
it's really cool
and dope or maluma big reggaeton star
who's now the most
famous person in instagram terms that
we've ever gotten on
and those people come on the platform
and they're seeing
other interesting people they see the
impact and and then when you start
getting more and more of those people
than others come on like that vincente
fox the president of
ex-president of mexico is on camden now
so
you start looking at that and then if
you're tony blair if you're
you know george w bush under obama
suddenly it's like
wow okay cool my peers are there so this
business is built brick by brick
relationship by relationship it all
starts with
having a very high nps product for both
the customers and defense
josh ellman wants to know what's the
weirdest place that people like to
record
uh the toilet i think that's always
funny
um dwight howard went
viral earlier this year for literally
being on the [ __ ] and making a cameo
um
we spooked it for april fools we
actually
um we we did a fake product launch we
called it cameo
now and the whole idea was like the
second you booked this celebrity their
front-facing camera would just turn on
and we catch them like wherever they are
and you know
it might be like lindsay lohan blending
a smoothie and just looking up
but but we we've had some fun with that
i think that's
that's probably uh the weirdest we
haven't had
um trying to yeah that's
i think the toilet is probably the
funniest but you know some especially
the tiger kings like you've got a doc
antoine one he's like literally
with the lions and they're there i mean
the tigers
so watching cameos is pretty enjoyable
how do you think about deep fakes or
like generative media and
is that a advantage coming down the pipe
for you guys is that something that you
guys have to
to kind of fight against and kind of
just what's the thoughts there
if cameo is the new autograph it becomes
inevitable that there will be just like
in the
in the analog world right there are
autographs in their forgeries that is as
old as time
uh the dens there's big dead sleeve
scrolls out there right so
forgeries have always been a thing and i
think if cameo
truly is the new autograph there will be
you know forgeries
in the digital world as well and i think
deep fakes are just
scratching the surface of that
technology at scale
i believe that a cameo video
like that watermark will be this that
will be the certificate of authenticity
in the digital age
and and i think again you know some
people well could they
if they they you know put the watermark
on the deep fake like
the technology will be there but i think
we will develop a core competency around
authenticity and our value our our
our mission at him is to create the most
personalized and authentic fan
experiences on earth so authenticity is
always going to be something that
i think is a core competency for our
business and we're going to have to
continue to iterate
technology is going fast deep fakes you
know there's
crazy things happening um but i think
when people come to canberra.com
or or in our app they know that what
they're getting is real and that's
important
so you obviously have a lot of pride and
a lot of early investors have pride in
having built the company in chicago
maybe talk a little bit about the
chicago tech scene eric carr
uh said basically he wanted to know
about your favorite places to eat
but uh i figured we'll talk about the
tech scene it's then
uh sure so the chicago tech scene
is uh was has was and has been extremely
important to candia's growth um
i truly believe that if i had built
i i really don't believe that this
business could have been built
in san francisco i don't believe that
this business could have been built in
l.a
even though that's obvious place where
it was built um i think if we were
getting built in la that
depending on which angel investors had
come in there's so many vested interests
in
entertainment there that you know if you
took money from this person
then these people wouldn't work with you
there's just so much ego
around the entertainment business so the
fact that we were able to raise all of
our money very quietly in chicago
it kind of gave us the opportunity to be
like it's like a plant that gets watered
and nurtured and
and all that happened and once we had
this strong foundation then when the
press kind of learned about it
and hollywood kind of learned about it
we'd already
got to a point where like we had hit
some escape from velocity
and one thing that's really interesting
about chicago
while it's not known as a tech hotbed
like chicago is
famous for its marketplace businesses
right like literally the board of trade
and and the cboe like there's 150-year
legacy of building great marketplaces in
chicago
you know that's why groupon came out of
here that's why grubhub came out of here
raise.com and spot hero were some you
know other
marketplaces where those founders really
kind of took me under their wing
and and you know the best businesses in
chicago have been
marketplaces and um and as somebody that
was building a marketplace like
to have people like you know matt
maloney or
the ceo of grubhub i mean in 2017 i
remember
we were on the phone and he's like
stephen i built the biggest marketplace
that's ever been built in chicago you're
building one that will be way bigger
than mine
if you don't [ __ ] it up because you were
because you were selling
bits i'm some bits people sorry you're
selling bits i'm selling apps
meaning nobody cares about how many
pizza parlors i have on grubhub in new
york
if i'm in los angeles your town are
global their fans are all over the world
and location isn't a variable and you
know hearing things like that from
people like him
as an entrepreneur it gives you
confidence that you start to
realize like wow i'm on to something and
and i think
you know the the presence of people like
mike gamson who
you know very quietly like gave me the
everything i needed
and then 1871 the tech incubator uh in
chicago
you know it's one of those things that
you know
the critics will say like hey you know
chicago loves to pump its chest about
having the world's best incubator but
who's really come out of there
all it takes is one cameo to come out of
there and for us if we ring the bell and
it really works
that like that was the greatest
investment the city
and the universities and everybody could
have ever done because
if cameo wins it can literally be one of
those tentpole companies that could
transform
the whole ecosystem and and the the
biggest thing that chicago lacks it
lacks
you know that steady parade of exits and
winners and you know
billion dollar companies exiting you
know early employees
uh having their equity and their options
that they took
like turning into cash like people at
cameo
in many ways like because they haven't
seen they don't look around like in the
valley
where they see their friends were early
at this company and it changed their
life
right and in chicago you know my
employees are look like they're sitting
on goldmines and a lot of times they
don't know it because
they don't see other people that have
been successful and that's one of the
reasons it's been personally
important to me to build this company
here to make sure that
you know the next me like when i was 21
years old i remember telling my mom
mom if i didn't have the trading job i
would have to go to new york i'd have to
go to la and have to go to san francisco
there's literally nothing for me to do
here unless i want to work in groupon
and and frankly like my hope is that the
next me the 21 year old version of me
that's at
you know michigan or at northwestern or
at university of
uh illinois or at wisconsin they're in
the they're in the midwest
they look at companies like cameo they
feel like
they can come work at one of those they
don't have to go to the valley to go
work at a facebook or google
they can go work at a home-grown one but
more importantly they can see people
that look like them that grew up
like them that went to the city schools
that they went to
that that [ __ ] you know hit it and i
think if you see that
that that's really the most important
thing and chicago
really fosters that and um you know it's
interesting now our headquarters was
sold uh by the landlord uh we've
we're now fully distributed and we've
actually decided that we're not gonna go
back to offices we're gonna stay fully
distributed
out of that now that doesn't mean cameo
is no longer a chicago company
it doesn't mean that it's an la company
it doesn't mean that it's a new
it means that if you were talented and
you're out there and you want to work
for cameo
you don't have to live in chicago and
you don't have to live in l.a
talent is evenly distributed around the
globe opportunities not
so the fact that we can go fish in
multiple ponds now
i think that can help us avoid some of
the pitfalls that
chicago companies tend to have namely a
lack of executive
bench you know there are very few people
that have
have kind of been there done that so now
the fact that
you know we can bring in great people if
they're in the valley they're in new
york they're in
uh seattle they're in austin texas like
wherever they are they can come work for
us
but the early people were here and
and if this wins then those people win
and then those people become the next
founders or the next angel investors
and you just need that flywheel going
and and
all it takes is one and for those people
that you know talk about 1871 and they
say you know nobody
nobody's come out of it we're all the
logos i mean look at any venture firm
right if you're a venture
in a venture portfolio you might make 40
bets maybe only one or two of those are
really going to work and everything else
go to zero
so if you're looking at a stage before
venture found these are just
entrepreneurs with an idea that have
nothing that are coming there yeah of
course 99.9 businesses
percent of businesses suck right and
people are gonna be there and they're
gonna
play entrepreneur and they're gonna you
know come every day and try and dream
but like
i love that that place exists and and i
hope that
you know cameos ultimate success is the
validation
for that because that place ex the fact
that that place
existed that kept me home in chicago and
had me
build the company here and without that
place i would i wouldn't have been
people can't argue with the results man
and i learned a long time ago that
there's nothing more fun than winning
and if you could do it with the pl the
people that you grew up with or the
place that you grew up in
uh it's kind of just a middle finger
that everybody tells you you can't but
the winning is the most important thing
right
i mean i remember when tech started
chicago turned us down
because they're like this business can't
be built in chicago you're gonna have to
go to the coast
all your money's gonna have to come
because that's what everybody said
but at the end of the day like i will
always
i have to win that's the most important
thing cameo has to win
so if there was ever a point where like
where i physically am like if it was
better for me to go to la
i'm there in a second right but it's
important for the ecosystem that cameo
wins because if cameo wins chicago wins
couldn't agree more what's the biggest
lesson you've learned running the
company over the last couple of years
the biggest lesson i've learned running
the company
the value of uh the value of mentorship
and coaching
right like as an athlete you know i
played hockey
uh my whole life played football playing
baseball but
through college and hockey and one of
the things that i always
you know looked at was the difference
between like having an exceptional coach
and shitty coach is so different
and you know for a company like cameo
i'm running this
business with like a bunch of my friends
who essentially
we're all doing this for the first time
right we're all first-time
uh founders first time executives every
one of my senior management is
is basically uh running the biggest team
that they've ever run
but you know what we lack for an
experience like you know we've
picked up a lot you know in four years
of running a hyper growth business
you know it's like like we're running so
fast and sometimes when we brought
people in we have real them
but the one thing that i've just learned
is that by continuing to invest in your
co-founders
and your and your key executives and
your early employees
you know who have like what one of my
ceo coaches called the vampire blood
right
they're kind of they got to spend time
with the founders they
they're they're missionaries that are
not mercenaries right
later like people that joined cameo
before
you know we had raised any money right
those are the true those are true
believers now other people will believe
as they come to have it
but you know sometimes like at this
point there's people that are joining
cameo because it's like oh
well this is the next billion dollar
business and you know i come here and i
can make a lot of money but
we're really a mission oriented place
and i think
i think everybody talks about how you
know you can't win without the best team
and
you know at linkedin jeff leader every
all hands used to say
you know talent is our number one
priority and as ceo
you've learned how true that is you've
got to have the right talent there
but i think one thing that i've learned
is that every time i've hired for a
resume
over kind of potential i found that
that ultimately like that didn't work
out for us and the best hires we ever
made are people that are in stretch
roles
that are curious that have a lot of grit
they want to get better and by
surrounding them with world-class
coaches like
you know for me bing gordon has been the
guy for me that's just changed my life
you get world-class coaches around you
know you and your team like that
that i mean that pays dividends like you
wouldn't believe
what's the biggest obstacle for cameo
moving forward
the biggest obstacle is team building
again it's like just
finding uh great you know hiring great
people
uh developing great talent um
it always you know in a world where
we're distributed now
like we were famous for the culture that
we built and offices you walked into
cameo headquarters in chicago
you just felt special and now we're we
have a
i like to joke we have 134 offices
around the world
and you know we're hi we're back in a
hiring spree and we're
you know we're going to grow from 130 to
200 people in the next six months
and you know how do you maintain culture
you know via zoom and how do you build
trust with people you don't know
and it's very specifically for us it's
like you know we do want to hire some of
these
uh you know senior execs and then gordon
my ceo coach
uh i asked him i'm like baby what's
what's a hall of fame
what does a hall of fame executive team
look like for you
and he goes the best advice i ever got
about how to build a
hall of fame executive team came from
ray bork the hall of fame hockey player
because ray bourke you know for those of
you guys that don't know he played 19
years on the ball
bruins won a stanley cup in his 20th
season with the avalanche yeah i think
he got straightened halfway through the
season
so hall of fame player best defenseman
of his generation had never lifted the
stanley cup
and ray borg told banks to win the
stanley cup
you need one or two grizzled little vets
that want one last taste of glory that
have been there
but maybe they've never lifted the
stanley cup before
so their flame is burning blue but they
have all the experience
you need three to five like you know one
or two lines of other
worldly rookies that are too stupid to
know what they're up against but are
going to play
unbelievable hockey but then like the
most important thing is you have a core
that runs two to three lines deep
six to nine you know a plus players
who are at the peak of their career and
are going to play the best hockey for
the rest of their lives
or in the case of a management team for
the next six to nine years these are the
people that
you know forever are going to be known
as iowa's x cameo i was
the one that helped ring the bell right
and and it's not just
you know it's not just hiring the
biggest resume at everything team
building
is so important and and that to me made
sense so for us
it's finding you know uh someone on
on the operations side and someone on
the tech side that
have been there done that they've seen
the scale but they either
they either raised the you know stanley
cup one time early in their career want
to do it one more time
or they've you know maybe been the
number two or they've been
they've seen scale but they haven't been
the reason why they won
and we need to get a couple of those
people and see that is an
awesome answer uh bitcoin and crypto
what uh what are your thoughts or
experiences
so uh sir radloff and zach maritis and
some others ezreal laugh about this
um so i was making a lot of money in
college
zach and i were making cash you know
shooters taking five dollar cover from
everybody
and uh and zach told me he's like hey
you know i'm setting up a couple of
these uh these mines and
and you know i'm gonna do litecoin or
something like that this is probably
2012 i was trading and i'm at the time
i'm i'm an option
like what the [ __ ] are you talking about
i had no idea
and i'm just like you know he's like
just give me 10 g's
zach's like give me 10 g's like we'll
split this you know we'll split these
computers and start selling all this
stuff and i'm just like
you know no and then there's a guy named
dan romero who
uh you know from was that coinbase dan
was literally my
across the hall neighbor freshman year
at college i do
and i'm watching him and all these guys
and they got this coinbase thing
and dan was always my like he was always
that
that friend that like was playing with
the future like when we were in college
he's
the one messing on twitter i'm like why
are we on you know why are we on twitter
you always just kind of like like they
talk about
for what's next like go look at the
smartest people in the world and what
are they messing around with on the
weekends
like dan was always like he's somebody i
should have drafted and followed
more and i should have decided dan's
doing that he's pretty damn smart
and uh i trust him so i ended up not
getting into any crypto
uh i've never bought any bitcoin i've
never bought i
literally had never touched it and
i i could feel the bubble coming when my
mom and her friends were buying it
and i think they did pretty well they
bought it and it kind of felt like it
was going up and up and up
and at some point it's crashed and it's
just been there uh look i believe it's
the future i'm a huge fan of crypto
um i am uh also as someone who is a
professional options trader for five
years i have not traded a single option
since i left trading and not because i
don't care about the market i know how
much edge the professionals have
so for me if i can't have if i can't
have an edge if i can't have the most
information if i can't have
the best technology i'd rather not play
the game at all than like feel like i'm
getting front run by anybody
so i have that's my playing fit i've
never
owned any type of crypto
so there's people obviously that come on
all the time that are in that position
but there is nobody who comes on and
says dan romero was their
neighbor and freshman year in college
you know ryan radloff like all these
guys who
uh for those that don't know those names
are very big in the crypto space
and you've never touched it nevertheless
goldstein from
starting line you know he when he quit
chicago ventures he literally
you know he had made a lot of money in
crypto
and and he left his venture fund
and he basically was like stephen i will
personally
lead your speed round like like me
personally i'm going to raise the [ __ ] i
haven't rate
so like [ __ ] and zack has turned his
you know server money that 10 grand yeah
that turned into 25
grand into cameos friends and family and
you know
he's done pretty i'm sure he's going to
do pretty well on that unless we [ __ ] it
all up here
but uh but that's yeah i've never i've
never
traded any crypt i love that and i had
all the information about it too
and i and i believe the thesis so that's
the other thing it's not that i'm uh
it's not that i'm agnostic and it's not
that i'm a disbeliever
i just believe that if i cannot be
it's the same reason i have not traded
one single option since i did it
professionally for five years
if i can't be all in i'm i'm all out
it's a fair point
asking two questions to wrap it up uh
what is the most important book that
you've ever
read
i read a book a week um
i would actually go back to seventh
grade and the book called ender's game
and that was the book that really turned
me onto reading
and before that i didn't get it like
you know i'm greek so i was always like
a storyteller and i
loved history and i was i was a history
major
but when i read ender's game that was
the one that really turned me on to
to reading for for life and you know
at this point there's so many great ones
i mean as a ceo
i think uh hard thing about hard things
is just incredible
um you know i i i'm looking lurie at my
desk right now
um another one that i i think
was just you know transformative to me
like i love that shrug
um you know i i just finished
like i've read all glad well you know
the gladwell books like
those are another fun one but i think
the tipping point um you know which i
think was his first one
that to me really like as i think about
how you build
viral loops and how you build things
that stick and how you build trends like
that was one i've been thinking a lot
about
uh there was a book i read earlier about
category creation that a good friend
scott siegel gave to me
that's called play bigger that was
another one that
everything we did uh as we started
thinking about the name and cameo the
look
the bread it was all category creation
and we and
and that was really influential i mean
i've been reading a book a week since i
was in seventh grade
so i'm happy to you know go toe-to-toe
with anybody on
what's there come to my bookshelf
anytime and i'm sure i can pick a couple
good ones out
play bigger is a highly highly
underrated book
that one is fantastic yeah uh
you got seagull for that he gave me that
tip that what
[Laughter]
uh second question a little bit more fun
and then you get to ask me one to finish
up
is uh aliens believer or non-believer
yeah i mean look i think the universe is
pretty damn big
i think that it's crazy
to think that there's nobody else out
there so i'm going to bet the field
and i'll bet that there's something out
there with the right
you know recipe of life uh
other humans i would bet that there's
other humans in the world
somewhere it's somewhere in the universe
like literally you know 100
there's other types of life but i
believe that there's
literally human beings like you and i
that are somewhere else
maybe we'll meet up maybe we won't we'll
have to bet on you after that
we i've never had anyone say that that
is that is pretty good
uh you get asked me one question to
finish up what do you got for me
um all right so i
for new hires i i always ask uh a series
of
three questions but all right one of
them isn't relevant so i'm only gonna
ask you two
okay number one what is one interesting
thing about you that
nobody none of your listeners know so it
wouldn't be on your twitter it wouldn't
be on your linkedin and then second
what's your death row meal
what is wait what was the second
question what's your death room meal
death row meal uh mcdonald's for sure
um one for mcdonald's again i'd go make
chicken sandwich
with a uh a large fry and a mcflurry
nah i got m m's yeah yeah
m's on that one
uh you'll like this i uh every saturday
i basically uh either go mcdonald's or
domino's and
you know everyone gets all maxed oh
you know if somebody asked the question
we didn't answer about best food in
chicago
i have a very contributing take that
domino's pizza is the best pizza in
chicago
and uh people ridicule me for it all the
time but i will stand by it
but if you actually want to know good
eating i run an
instagram food blog that i'm not as
active on anymore
but it's off the bone o-f-f-d-a-b-o-n-e
on instagram
and it's all food you you can eat with
your hands so it's basically
big pieces of meat um you know from some
of the best steakhouses in the world
so if you're into that type of thing
check it out on instagram
you can see what i eat my right through
there anything i put on is standby
i love that the fact that you say
domino's is the best in chicago i know
you get a hard time for that
because people give me a hard time in
new york like what do you mean how is
that possible
look man it's just consistent you know
what you're gonna get all your time
every time i'm with you yeah uh most
interesting thing
um i don't know i'm like pretty
transparent about everything so
the hard part is like that people
wouldn't know um i would say
i'll give you an example so you don't
know about me
in 1988 i was chicago's best looking
baby i literally won an award in the
chicago tribune
so there's got to be something like that
in your life that i hope
you know is is equal that you know you
can be proud of maybe you never told
anybody
do you start do you start the interview
with new hires with that fact
is that is that how you just immediately
put this yeah
i got more where that came from but
that's you know that's one that really
blows people's mind yeah that one's
pretty good
it's hiding under the cove yeah that
one's pretty good
uh i'm trying to think what uh if we go
like way back when we were younger
um well well this one's pretty
funny uh the day that i met my now wife
uh it would go to a coffee shop and uh
playing uh
football i basically have this finger
that i tore a ligament
and uh you know waited like eight months
to go get it fixed and they couldn't fix
it fully and so somehow in the middle of
the conversation i was looking look you
got to chill out like i can't get
married
and so you know kind of i got what i
deserved on that one
well that's awesome i saw the finger
poking out and i was gonna ask you about
it
[Laughter]
yeah i feel like like weird stuff like
that uh i grew up with
four brothers for your finger
[Laughter]
you have brothers and sisters i've got a
little brother
okay so uh big shout out to my brother
john came up with the name oh really
yeah he's actually a big crypto guy so
he made me listen
uh so i got four younger brothers and so
if you grew up in a family with just
boys you'll get this but uh
probably the things that people don't
know are like just the all-out brawls my
brothers and i had as kids like
i've got brothers with staples in the
back of their head like all kinds of
crazy stuff
where people are just like wait a minute
when you were 12 like you guys were
putting each other in the you know in
the doctor's room and in the hospital
yes like that is literally what happened
iron sharpens iron right
absolutely all right where can we send
people cameo.com what what's your
twitter account
yeah come see us at cameo.com we are at
bookcameo on twitter unfortunately
because
cameo has been squatted by cameo wood
for
years her name is cameo and she won't
give it up
i've offered her a lot of money if you
guys want to maybe get started like a
gofundme with some
you know crypto and maybe we can have a
compelling thing
or if you guys just want to do what i
like to do just just tag anytime you buy
a cameo just tag
cameo anyways and uh that's always a lot
of fun
uh i'm at mr 312 mr
then the number 312 chicago's area code
on twitter
so uh you know this is a lot of fun and
you know hope you guys all enjoying
uh cameo and if you got special requests
of people
that we need on tweet it at book cameo
or at me
and we'll do our best to get them out
there for you
all right everyone that is uh chicago's
prettiest baby from 1988
signing out we'll do this again soon man
thanks awesome thank you